hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
what we're going to do together in this
video is we're going to talk about how
to find the angle between two lines okay
using the formula okay that we're gonna
be discussing in this video so you've
got your two lines and you're trying to
find that angle between the two lines so
here's our formula it's the tangent of
theta equals the absolute value of the
difference between the two slopes okay
of the two lines divided by one plus the
product of the two slopes of the two
lines so let's take a look at some
examples and you'll understand a bit
better how this works so in this first
example our two lines are y equals 2x
minus 3 and y equals 5x plus 1
I've graphed the two lines here for us
and what we can see is that we're trying
to find that angle between the two lines
so let's go ahead and apply our formula
so you can see that the slopes are two
and five so that's where we're going to
be using in our formula there so we've
got tangent of theta equals 5 minus 2 ok
over 1 plus 5 times 2 okay so if we
simplify that down we get 3 over okay 10
plus 1 which is 11 okay absolute value
of that is still going to be positive 3
11s that's the tangent of theta then
what we have to do is just do the
tangent inverse okay to find theta to
find the angle so it's the tangent
inverse of 3 11s let's go to the
calculator let's just see what that is
so we've got tangent inverse of 3
divided by 11 and we get M
15.3 degrees so that looks about right
it's a real small angle here between the
two lines so that's going to be 15 point
three degrees okay let's look at another
example so in this example we know the
slope of this line is 4 we don't know
the slope of the line above here so
we're going to rewrite this in slope
intercept form so that's going to be
negative 6y equals negative 3x plus 2
we're going to divide everything by
negative 6 so that's going to give us y
equals 1/2 X okay minus 1/3 and you can
see the slope of this line is 1/2 the
other line it's 4 is going to be 4 so
let's go ahead and use our formula
so the tangent of theta equals 4 minus
1/2 over 1 plus 4 times 1/2 okay so if
we simplify that down what do we get we
get this is 8 halves minus 1/2 is 7
halves K over 4 times 1/2 is 2 plus 1 is
3 okay and so then you can see this is
actually going to be let's see when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal right so
this is going to be 7 6 and we're taking
the tangent theta equals 7 6 we want to
take the inverse tangent to find the
angle so theta is going to be tangent
inverse of 7 divided by 6 that will give
us the angle between the two lines so
let's go to the calculator let's see
what that comes out to we've got tangent
inverse see tangent inverse of 7 sixths
and we've got 49 point four degrees so
that's our angle so theta equals 49
point four all right so I hope you learn
how to work with this formula to find
the angle between two lines go ahead and
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos and I look forward to
seeing you in the future ones I'll talk
to you soon